I want to try and save up as much money
as I can for the next two to three to
four years right and I want to basically
buy a piece of land and put a mobile
home on it and just try to pay it off in
one big chunk uh if you bought a piece
of land and put an very very very very
inexpensive trailer on
it that would mean you'd be living
rentree yeah and you could you know very
quickly then save up the money to build
a house and get rid of that trailer but
whatever you pay for that trailer is
going to be lost
money so we're not talking about $30,000
and we're not talking about $20,000
we're talking about $10,000 or
less yeah which ain't much
dude this is not a high standard of
living here